садівник алехін
навчальні 2016 руку на платформі та д-ра
вет було за інтерактивні обговорення
програми з математикою результати яка
був і за твердині наказом міністерство про
світою наукою України
вага 5 серпня 16 уроку т.п.
вже не за чудською школою навчаються за він
вогняну програму з математика
розділеному джерелу знак іванівни та
програми буренін usb а передню
редакцію програми ми навчання
математики в шану кави школі на
змінилася і поля гаї
про формування розуму краще за школу риф
предметну математично це ключових
компетентностей
знак та предметні математичні
компетентності подано на слайді ми на вч
а йому дітей математикою не радує
овочі он і по ви не впаду водицею
початковий предмет а за раді підготовкою
їхні будинки та будні року рослого жити а вже
вид до зміїного світла
сьогодні не мажу його у я випити після де
але the prophecy іншу діяльність людей
на базовий курс таня математичних
методів для розв'язання проблем там і
навіть важливі ви мені розуміння іншу
роль і математик та купи знань
ефективності здати низ логічно світ кого
ти за 100 золота та суспільство не навички про
початкових з навальних то практика
забинтовані в ситуаціях, а нові не
програмі по ременю
bull і розширення cola ключових
компетентностей
крем міняли тис а про нову не програму
на калоші на потреби логічно світ кого
ти як дурнів і предметну
компактністю дав у мене критичному якщо
ти на готовності до розв'язання проблем
та застосування їм так зведу
математичної діяльності для вирішення
повсякденних завдань і до перекликається з
вид по видну предметну компетентність
розпізнавання проблем річки розв'язуються
та засмоктуванні математичних методів на
вміння проти ти в команді замість
чани математики у підкові школі за
безтурботне формування в учинів зрозуміти
з числа у magic мільйону на путіному та
заг якщо вільних новачок усних так з
нових товариствами навчання розв'язання з
від них завдань які ж моделями цілих
ситуацій вен я з балансу ванним і
переверни бага темрява дихає і летимо і
шкільній практиці саме у вирує кови
школі
вже не бувають математичні
компетентності на рівні ключові
компетентності якани orchid на люди не
для ефективної та жити ідеальності
крем того місця чіткого курсу математики
складати основу для подалі
вчення математики в основній школі та
треба йогор не могли влади для
формування ключових компетентностей
не орхідних людей не 21 столиця виходить
надзвичайно значущого оновлення
програми в основному уведу лося не за
рахунок
привнесенням шах елементів з місця ви
лучині пивних харчування а за рахунок
розван теж не державних ви міг до ременя
завального середню при готуванні
формулювання їх відразу милу для батька
нову яко і в передні редакції
програми у нові не програмі
реалізована принцип ножиць якорі
означає ще не для всіх елементів з
місця у програмі поставлена ​​у відповіді
є ви можу я україни харчування які мають
розряду тася на уроці олл-іни петля
горить щеплення
питча складу не пари вірних то
контрольних рубає в 4 травня orient увата
абсолютно ті результати навчання столітті
ви і значення державним і ви мохаммеду
ременя загальна вас we knew підготовки
вчинивши навідаю з потрібно
пертуссин за такого підходу можна
реалізувати елементи вибір ідеального
навчання ефект тіні всякого до видано
бага темрява 10 листами інноваційну
шкільній практиці харчування річки знаю
вже ним у передній іванів чиня
на етапі їх вірджинія приймаються тут
ми без технологічних париж код стрес
у клімату підносячи але в класі і вже не
зрізаним і пізнавали ми вимагатимемо і
різьбленими початковими можливостями як
свічки та не психологи
with my nose тіунів чаю масті вже не в
1 класу вид носиться як-1 до 10 с
означає
я хочу взятий з бідності на з локшину півдні
ціни за одиницю
то з давнини до навчання найсильніше
стану вигадати 10 балів і дали у
процесу навчання
c розрив не скоро чується на спокій
збилася
сьогодні в читальний може orient уват осі
на середнього вже не риба дати оптимальні
навантаження
з лап кому та сильному вченими краще не
можна знаєш у цій ривай складно
стинів чиня виходить через можливості
солодких врахувавши ми форму йому мої
будні нашої держави
я кому бо чомусь економічно розв'язану з
високим і видним розвитку наукою
технологій а за пару каюті у
я під потрібний потенціал наших людей
виходиш з вище за значить ми за кликаємо
у чіпі лив аналізу ватою програму
виставляю чи його колонку вниз на в
чане то право колонку тримаючи мені ви мовляв
це ременя завального відомості
підготовкою ввічливий і ви означає і які
харчування пропан вулиця вчинивши див цією
вибір ідеального навчання
см цією задавав не потреб учень з
високим гребенем з 90 до навчання
ояки харчування та взуття скуті для
розуміння всім а вже не ми і пропонувалося
перекласти і головне на якому рівні у
знімають про панова ти їх на даному етапі
на у чині